yes you read that title correctly we now
have
leaks and rumors about apple working on
a 15-inch macbook air
and if you don't know how big of a deal
that is let me explain it to you
there has never been a 15-inch macbook
air
the only apple laptop to ever get a
display larger than 13.3 inches
is the 15 and 16 inch macbook pro
and those models are much more expensive
with the current 16-inch pro
starting at a huge 2400 so if apple was
to release a 15-inch air
that would be incredible and it would be
a game changer
because it would allow users who want a
macbook with a large display
to get in at a much lower price
especially with all of the changes we're
expecting for
future macbooks so in this video what
i'm gonna do is take a look at a bunch
of leaks and rumors
surrounding the next macbook air and
then i'm gonna talk about both sides of
the
argument concerning if a 15-inch air is
realistically gonna come out or not
because there are some rumors going
against this
but i'll get into that in just a minute
as many of you know the most recent
macbook air update came back in november
with the very first apple silicon m1
chip
and if you've seen any of our reviews
you'll know that the m1 macbook air is
currently
the best value macbook ever made
by far and all of the new m1 max have
been behind
the huge jump in max sales that apple
experienced in the previous quarter
even though the only thing that changed
was the chip
so obviously the m1 max are a huge
success
but now let's take a look into the
future with recent macbook air leaks
back in december minchikwe reported that
we should be getting
two redesigned macbook pros in 2021
which we now know
will be the 14 and 16 inch models but he
also mentioned that we should be getting
a new macbook air
in 2022 yes that's next year
not this year which is weird because
apple has recently been
at least refreshing the macbook air
every eight to nine
months but then again some of those were
very minor changes
quo himself said that it should
definitely be getting an updated apple
silicon chip
and a brand new mini led display which
is something
that we've been waiting for for years
now and to make that rumor even better
digitimes basically said the same thing
a new mini led macbook air
launching in 2022 but the most
interesting rumor
came from bloomberg's mark germain who
said that the redesigned thinner and
lighter macbook air
could potentially come in the second
half of this year
which does not match up to the other two
reports that we saw earlier
however he did say that the new macbook
air will include
apple's magsafe charging technology and
the next-gen version of the m1 apple
silicon chip now if you didn't already
know what macsafe is
it's apple's magnetic charging system
for older macbooks
like the 2017 macbook air and apparently
they're bringing it back and if you're
wondering what else is going to be
redesigned
we can get a pretty good idea by looking
at the leaks and rumors
surrounding the macbook pro just last
month quo reported that the new macbook
pros
would be getting a new flat edged form
factor design
similar to the iphone 12 which makes
sense because the ipad pro already has
that
the pro display xdr already has that and
the imacs are rumored to be getting that
as well
he also said that the macbook pros will
be getting a max safe charging port
apple silicon chips and more types of
ports
which he later mentioned could be both
an sd card slot
and an hdmi port and then just a couple
of days ago
we got rumors of a redesigned 14-inch
macbook pro
with a new mini led display with slimmer
bezels
now most of that we should expect to
trickle down to the next macbook
air especially the new flat edge design
which i'm extremely excited for
but in terms of the port situation mark
german says that it's just gonna come
with the regular old pair of usb4 ports
so the extra variety of ports might be a
macbook pro exclusive but the
absolute weirdest thing that mark german
said
was that the current macbook air would
remain
in the company's lineup as an
entry-level offering
so this would mean that the new
redesigned macbook air
would not replace the current m1 model
which might sound a bit weird but it
totally makes sense if you really think
about it
back in 2018 when apple revealed the
redesigned
13-inch macbook air for 1300.
they actually kept the old model with
the crazy thick silver bezels for sale
on their website
for only 999 all the way up until they
refreshed the new model again
and only then did they finally take the
old model
off of their website and i don't know if
you've noticed this or not
but ever since 2019 apple has been
slowly dropping the
price of that new macbook air down to
the current
999 level the same price
as that super ancient 2017 model was
so what if apple's master plan all along
was to bring down the price of the
current macbook air so that they could
come out with a totally redesigned
macbook air
and sell it at a higher 1300 price tag
essentially doing exactly what they did
back in 2018.
this is a genius move by apple because
the people who want that new redesign
will pay the extra cash for that 1300
model and the people who simply want the
least expensive apple laptop
will be totally happy paying 900 to a
thousand dollars
for the current m1 macbook air with the
older design
which is still an excellent laptop
that's literally the best move that
apple could make
but now let's factor in the possibility
of a larger 15-inch macbook air model
and why that would make sense for apple
to do first off
just a few days ago we got a rumor
posted on mac rumors
about apple developing a larger 15 inch
macbook air
this would be totally awesome for a lot
of people because i personally believe
there are people out there
who really want a macbook with a larger
display
but don't want to pay a crazy high 2400
for the 16-inch macbook pro so imagine
if there was a 15-inch macbook air
for let's say 15 to 1600
that had more than enough performance
for a lot of people due to the switch to
apple silicon
as well as being thin light and
completely
fanless this could totally be doable at
that price tag
because with the current 16-inch pro
model a lot of that high
2400 price comes from being forced into
paying
for more storage more ram much more
performance
a better cooling system and more so for
someone who just
wants that large display they can pay 15
or 1600 dollars
for a 15 inch macbook air with much
lower specs
and a less powerful chip and i know i'm
not alone in this thinking because we
recently ran a poll on our channel
and 37 percent of people who bought the
more expensive 15 and 16 inch macbook
pro models
bought one mainly because of the bigger
display size
so there's definitely a market out there
for the 15 inch air
we also got a few comments from users
saying that their dream macbook
would be a 15 or 16 inch macbook air
because they're already happy with the
level of performance that the 13 inch
offers
but they just want a larger display so
as you can tell there's definitely a
market for it
and i think that from apple's
perspective this could bring in
extra revenue because i feel like people
who want a big display
but can't afford the 16 inch pro for 2
400
are simply just going for the cheaper 13
inch model instead
now on the other hand there are also
some pretty good reasons
why we won't be seeing a 15-inch macbook
air anytime soon
so let's jump into the other side of the
argument
first off if we go back to that leak
about apple developing a 15-inch air
apparently apple decided not to move
forward with this model
for the upcoming generation and instead
chose to stick with the 13 inch size
again while reducing the bezel size for
a smaller
overall footprint well that's definitely
a bit disappointing
and i guess if you think about it apple
would rather upsell their much more
expensive 16 inch macbook pro
to the people who really care about
display size because it's already been
working
in recent years and then if we dig a
little bit deeper
a 15 inch macbook air for 15 or 1600
dollars
would end up costing more than their
base 13 inch macbook pro for
1300 which wouldn't really make sense
because the pro line should logically be
more expensive
so because of those reasons i don't
think we'll be seeing a 15 inch air
anytime soon
but the totally redesigned 13-inch air
is definitely coming
and i think we figured out when apple is
going to release it
because of how groundbreaking the
current m1 macbook air already is
apple totally doesn't have to update it
until
2022 just like the rumors are pointing
to
in fact i personally believe that we
won't be seeing a new macbook air
until it gets a brand new m2 chip
built on tsmc's three nanometer
architecture
because right now they're still stuck
with the five nanometer
so even if they make a new chip it's not
really going to be any more efficient
which is what matters the most for the
macbook air and as of right now
tsmc is expected to have the three
nanometer chips ready
in the fall of 2022 and that's when i
think
the fully redesigned macbook air with
the m2 is coming
and if you think that's way too long of
a wait we believe that apple is going to
be focusing more on the pro machines
until then like for example the fully
redesigned 14
and 16 inch macbook pros coming around
this summer
with the m1x chip and then the m1x or
m1z
redesigned imax coming in the fall or
maybe even the winter
and then next year in 2022 we're finally
going to be getting the redesigned
macbook air
and a redesigned base 1300 macbook pro
with an m2 chip which will be weaker
but more efficient than the m1x on the
higher end models
of course until they come out with the
m2x chip so that's basically my personal
speculations for the macbook release
timeline
and now i want to finish off by
answering one
final question should you wait for the
redesigned macbook air
well if you know that you're not willing
to wait over a full year
to end up paying a higher 1300 price
for the redesigned macbook air then i
would honestly just buy the current
m1 air right now for a thousand dollars
and enjoy it for all of those months
that you could have ended up waiting
or if you want some extra power then i
would simply wait for the m1x 14-inch
macbook pro
coming most likely sometime this summer
but keep in mind
that it's likely going to be priced at
around 1800 to 2
000 so if you're not willing to pay for
that
then seriously just buy the m1 macbook
air right now
because it's an absolutely killer value
so hopefully you enjoyed this video and
if you did
check out our macbook air review right
over there and click that circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]